-No, here's what I would do.
With one hand, I would mak
a lightning bolt on my forehead.
-Oh, "Harry Potter Curse of --
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
All right, all right,
and one of the words,
I would pretend that I'm
drinking out of something.
I would be sitting on a throne
[ Laughter ]
-"Harry Potter and the Kin
of Something."
-No, no, but what would I
be drinking out of?
-Mead.
-No, what would I
be drinking out of?
-Oh, "Goblet of Fire"!
"Goblet of Fire"!
-Yes, yes, yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's correct.
"Goblet of Fire."
-Oh, my gosh.
♪♪♪♪
-Everybody, I am here with the
one and only Amy Poehler.
Oh, we love you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Her new movie "Wine Country"
is out now and on Netflix soon
We're about to play a new twis
on a classic game, charades,
called "Shouting Charades.
Now, here's how it works.
Just like charades,
where you pick a clue,
try to get your partner
to guess.
The only difference is,
you can't use your hands
or your body at all.
You can only describe
how you would be moving.
And you have to shout it.
So, for example,
if the clue has five words
instead of holding up
five fingers, you would say,
"I'm holding up five fingers!"
-Yeah.
-Okay, good.
So, now, before we begin,
let's both put our arms
in the official shouting -
-I believe this is the first
time that we've played this.
Is that right?
This is the maiden voyage?
-It is.
-I'm sorry. I just --
I think that's exciting.
-It is the first time.
Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Only the best.
-All right.
-Only the best for you.
All right, we'll put our hands
in these -- these sleeves.
Now we can't physically get out.
We cannot do this. Okay.
-This is good,
'cause I am a gesticulator
-You are? Okay, good.
-I am.
You know what that means.
-Ready?
-Oh, Higgins,
good to see you, buddy.
This is Steve Higgins
right there.
Give it up for Steve Higgins
[ Cheers and applause ]
Sharp-dressed man.
Amy, you should go first.
-Thank you. I'm going to pic
lucky number seven.
-Oh!
-Number seven.
Okay.
-Mm-hmm.
-[ Laughs ]
Okay.
All right.
-Why would you touch me?
-[ Laughs ]
Okay, I'm standing up.
-Okay.
-And I'm holding up two fingers.
-Two words.
-Yes.
And then I'm also putting --
making action
like I'm doing something
with film, like I'm rolling --
-It's a movie.
-Yes.
-Oh, my God.
-Okay.
I'm holding up my two fingers.
-The same ones?
[ Laughter ]
-I'm holding up two fingers!
-Okay. Two words.
-Yes, I already told you that.
-Oh, the second word.
-Yes.
Okay. And then it's --
And then -- Oh.
-Hurry up!
-I'm moving around really fast
like what you were doing
up there.
Like I'm really grooving
to the music.
-Oh, yes, dance.
-Yes.
-Yes. Dancing.
-Moving, grinding.
-Yes.
No, the first word.
-Dancing.
-Yes, that's --
-"Dirty Dancing"!
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes, yes, yes, yes!
Love it!
-It's so hard.
-What number should I pick
What -- Four.
-Four.
-Four. A strong four.
Okay.
-Take your time there.
Oh, my gosh.
I can't see that.
-Got it?
-No. Yes.
-Yes.
-You sure?
-Okay.
-Yeah.
[ Audience groans ]
[ Laughter ]
-Whoa, the reaction.
-All right.
Start the clock.
All right, so I'm moving
my hands like I'm --
like it's something
that I'm going to read.
-A book.
-Yes.
-It's a book.
-Yeah, and it is --
-Hold --
-I think seven words.
-Okay.
-Oh, no.
I can't say that.
Sorry.
-You're holding up
seven fingers.
-I'm holding up seven fingers.
Sorry.
I'm going to say the...
-"Tale of Two Cities."
No.
-No, here's what I would do.
With one hand, I would mak
a lightning bolt on my forehead.
-Oh, "Harry Potter Curse of --
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
All right, all right,
and one of the words,
I would pretend that I'm
drinking out of something.
I would be sitting on a throne
[ Laughter ]
-"Harry Potter and the Kin
of Something."
-No, no, but what would I
be drinking out of?
-Mead.
-No, what would I
be drinking out of?
-Oh, "Goblet of Fire"!
"Goblet of Fire"!
-Yes, yes, yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's correct.
"Goblet of Fire."
-Oh, my gosh.
-Mead.
[ Laughs ]
I love you.
Oh, my gosh.
All right, last one.
Here we go, final round.
-"Goblet of Fire."
Three, please.
Three for me, please, Higs
-Three.
-Thank you, bud.
All right.
-It's getting a little steam
in my --
-Oh, okay.
Okay, okay.
-Got it?
-Yep, yep, yep.
It's getting steamy in here.
-It is steamy in there, right?
I don't want to --
I don't want to shake your han
when we're done.
'Cause it's really gross.
-All right, here we go.
-All right,
what would you be doing?
-Okay, I'm standing up.
I'm holding up three fingers
-Three words.
-Yes.
And then I'm making the sign
again that I'm rolling film.
[ Laughter ]
-Rolling film.
It's a movie.
-You know, like cranking film.
-Yes, cranking -- I understand
-Okay.
-And then I'm holding up
three fingers.
-Yes, three -- the third word.
-And I am placing something on
top of my head that is point
that makes me feel very regal.
And I'm in a throne.
And I'm --
-Crown.
-Yeah, and then I'm pointing
to myself after I do all that.
-Queen?
-Almost.
-Prince, king.
-Yes.
-So now I'm holding up
two fingers.
-Yes, the second word.
You're gesticulating
with your feet, by the way
[ Laughter ]
You can't help it.
You're like --
-There ain't no coats
for my feet.
My feet are free!
Okay.
And then I'm --
[ Buzzer ]
Aah!
-Oh, no!
Oh, no, sorry.
That was my fault.
It was my fault.
Wait. Just do it again.
Tell me the second word.
I'll get it.
-I'm holding up two finger
and I'm going like this.
Roar.
[ Laughter ]
-"The Lion King."
[ Cheers and applause ]
My thanks to the one and onl
Amy Poehler.
-We're about to play
a game of Charades.
Now, Chelsea and I are a team,
but we need opponents
and we found some
really good ones here.
First, he stars in the new movie
"La La Land,"
which opens everywhere
December 16th.
He has a brand new album
out today called
"Darkness and Light."
Give it up for John Legend
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Chelsea.
-Chelsea.
-John, Chelsea.
How are you?
Absolutely. John Legend.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Joining John's team, John, I
think you might recognize her.
Please welcome the lovely,
the talented
Chrissy Teigen, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's my wife.
That's your wife.
That's your wife
and your partner. Okay, good
Come on now.
Thank you so much.
-I was just hanging out
backstage.
-I know. We dragged you
out to do this.
I'm sorry.
Thank you for doing this.
-We get a two for one when w
come on this show.
-Now, everyone knows
how to play Charades.
Each player gets a turn giving
silent clues to their teammates.
30 seconds on the clock
per turn.
We're going to do four round
worth one point each.
5th round is a Charades
showdown.
Both teams give the same clu
at the same time.
Chrissy,
why don't you start us off
Chelsea, you and I
will sit over there.
John, you can stay there.
-Okay.
-We don't guess.
-Anybody? What do I go for
[ Indistinct shouting ]
Three.
-We don't guess on this.
-Okay.
-What does that mean?
Song?
Okay.
Boogie?
Boogie nights?
Dance?
Twist?
Do the twist?
Shake? Shake.
"Shake, Rattle and Roll."
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's because they're married.
-Can we use that?
-What's that?
That was a lot of shaking.
-A lot of shaking.
No, we love that.
We love that.
-That's good television.
-Okay.
All right, here we go.
Thank you, John.
-That was good.
[ Laughter ]
-Chelsea, we can do this.
All right, we can do this.
Shake, rattle and roll.
You didn't have any words,
nothing.
-All right.
-We got this.
[ Laughter ]
What number part--
-Eight!
-Ah, man. All right.
-Ah, [bleep].
-I think --
Chelsea, we can do this.
We can do this
-All right.
We can do this. Ready?
-Yeah.
Ready?
-Yes.
Sound. Song. Song.
-We just went over this.
-Song.
-Ready?
-Yeah.
One, two, three, four.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, four.
Times a lady.
[ Laughter ]
Song.
Eyes.
Oh, host?
Crawling on the floor.
Clawing, eyes.
Clawing.
Tiger, tiger, tiger, eyes.
[ Rambling ]
"Eye of the Tiger."
-Yes!
That's it!
That's how you do it!
Yes!
You did fine.
Come on, you're great.
-That was good.
-That's because your good.
-Oh, my God.
I said four words
is what I meant to say.
-Okay.
-Four words.
-John, you're up.
-What do you mean?
It keeps going?
-Oh, yeah.
John goes, and then you go
[ Laughter ]
John goes then you go.
-Oh, no.
-It'll be fun
-Here we go.
-Two.
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-Oh, confident.
-He doesn't look happy.
-Movie.
-Mm-hmm.
-Short?
-The big short?
Small, tiny?
Little.
"Little Women?
Little...
[ Laughter ]
Little -- little dress?
Little slinky, sexy?
Your fly is unzip, first of all.
-Oh, my...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
And you're yelling --
you're yelling little.
You're yelling little!
-It's a party.
Hey, I wasn't done.
-You're yelling -- Look, you'r
yelling little sexy.
Little sexy.
-Okay, okay, okay, okay.
-No, that's not little.
-I was rudely interrupted.
-No, I'm not saying that.
We knew that's not little.
Okay.
Little giants, little giants
-"Little Mermaid."
-Oh, "Little Mermaid."
-You gotta do like the flip.
-I didn't -- I didn't know
-You're up, you're up.
-I was like making my legs
into flippers.
-It was good, it was good.
-I'm sorry.
-It was my fault.
I wasn't good enough.
-Chelsea, wait.
No one saw that.
No one saw...
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God.
Chelsea.
[ Laughter ]
Song, song.
-Yeah.
-Dancing queen?
Sing, sing...
Crown? Sing on me?
Flash dance?
[ Laughter ]
Sing out?
First -- fir--
Down? Rain?
-Yes.
-Rain. Sing rain.
Rain -- "Purple Rain?"
Rain sing? Rain dance?
Sing ring?
-Oh, my God!
Sing shower?
Song shower?
-Wait?
Are you serious right now?
-Ring song? Ring song?
-He knows it!
Everyone her knows it!
-Stop it. Stop it.
-You -- you missed it
on purpose.
-Stop it. Hey!
Get back here! Wha--
What was it?
-Oh, my God.
-What's your problem?
You knew it?
-"Singin' in The Rain."
-♪♪ Singin' in the rain ♪♪
-Everybody knew it
except for you.
[ Laughter ]
-That's not --
You ever seen the movie?!
They don't do that at all.
They're dancing around.
They dance and stuff,
with umbrellas and --
Oh, my gosh!
You give the clue.
-Guys.
-Me?
I'm better at guessing.
-My blood pressure's like...
Seriously, my pacemaker
is going crazy right now.
It's the last --
This is the showdown.
-My fly is up,
just so everyone knows.
-Everyone --
Now my fly is down.
I don't know know that happened.
-[ Laughs ]
All right, let's go.
Let's have the battle right now.
She's gonna give.
-All right, Chrissy.
You give, me and you.
We're going to give
at the same time, all right?
However gets it gets all the
points and the respect.
-The same card?
-Uh-huh.
-So we should look
at both of you guys then.
-Oh, yeah.
-You can look at both of us.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Which one.
-Nine!
-He just screamed out nine
Like, "Nine!"
All right, here we go.
Ready?
-[ Laughs ]
-Okay.
Chelsea, what are you
laughing at?
Are you ready?
Stop laughing.
Is my fly open?
All right, ready?
Go.
-At the same time.
Movie, movie.
Book, book,
you're reading a book.
There's a book.
Hourglass figure.
-Nutcracker?
Running.
-Running man.
Woman?
Run.
-[ Laughs ]
-Run of the...
Give me another word.
-Guess something!
Guess something!
-Girl.
Girl on the run? Girl.
-Running. Running for cover.
Come on! Oh, my gosh!
-Running babies?
Bicycling?
Choo-choo, the horn.
Honk the horn. Bus on the trai
goes, choo, choo, choo.
[ Laughter ]
-What is it?
-Bus on the train goes...
-Oh, my God.
-Girl on the train.
-It is girl on a train,
that is exactly it.
Thank you.
I'm gonna give it.
I have to give it.
-We won!
-I have to give
to Team Legend right here.
Chrissy Teigen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Choo, choo!
-My thanks to Chelsea Handler,
Chrissy Teigen,
John Legend.